this book is different from other
corporate governance books on the market
and that it's really evidence driven the
way we structured the book is around
facts and evidence so what we do with
each section is we start with an idea we
explain how it works and what the
positives and the negatives are of
different approaches to governance and
then we look at the data on how
prevalent certain things are out there
in the market and we follow it up with
academic research that tests whether
these things are positive or negative
and we draw our conclusions from that a
lot of the books that are on the market
today are really opinion based so they
start with a central premise and then
the author spends the majority of the
book defending why that premise is
correct a lot of it is based on that
person's opinions and in some cases
biases but they're not really evidence
driven and in many cases those
conclusions may or may not be true but
they're not really tested
I think the most surprising finding from
the book is that a lot of the focus is
misdirected in governance today a lot of
the attention is placed on features of
governance so for example what's the
structure of the Board of Directors how
much compensation is paid to CEOs and
things like that and a lot less
attention is paid on the factors that
really matter and these are the
processes by which the company actually
makes decisions so for example a lot
less attention is played is paid to the
strategy and risk management functions
and those are areas where boards can
really stand to improve another area
where boards can stand to improve is
with its CEO succession a lot of CEO
succession planning within corporations
is was shown to be a more check-the-box
solution and not really what we expected
we expected that companies would have
operational plans in place things that
they could do if the CEO suddenly
stepped down and they needed to find
somebody right away and I think going
forward a lot can improve with a new
focus on the features and of how
governance is run rather than just these
superficial factors I think the most
surprising finding of the research is
that how little impact the research has
actually had on practice
there's tons of academic research across
accounting finance economics corporate
strategy and things like that
lots of careful thought but I don't
think that research has had that much
impact in the way people actually think
about it you know the Blue Ribbon panels
that are filled with clearly well-known
people very smart very successful when
you read their reports there's actually
not much discussion of of the research
that either supports and doesn't support
some of the findings I think one of the
things that we hope the book does is
provides a synthesis of the research in
a digestible form that the press
directors lawyers you know government
regulators and alike can actually see
that there is a there's a body of work
out there that informs you know you
don't have to do it yourself it's
already being done as part of the
scholarship in universities so when we
we're actually a little surprised how
little impact that sort of sort of had
in in these things other kind of more
practical things that and we found
surprising are the inability of boards
they actually put in put in operational
succession plans this is a really a key
part of risk management and it's it's a
pretty it's a pretty serious part of of
what boards do I mean ultimately they
evaluate and vet the strategy the
organization they kind of hire and fire
the top management and so you know one
of the two issues seems to be lacking a
little bit
that boards are struggling
with lots of things with regard to CEO
pay now that's not that surprising in
and of itself but the SEC has recently
required boards to talk about or the pay
practices motivating managers to do
excessive risk-taking that sounds like
something that board out evaluate but I
think we don't really know at this point
how do you define excessive risk-taking
you know what would it look like you
know and then the issue is you know how
can you evaluate that and so we actually
have some proposals or you know sort of
hopefully informed guesses about you
know new ways to think about pay how
much incentive are you really providing
and when it when are you in a situation
we start worrying about excessive
risk-taking one of the examples that we
have in the in the book has a deal with
Eli Lilly and they they went through and
did a very detailed assessment of
excessive risk-taking and their response
was to basically you know take out all
the lots of the incentive contracts so
you got rid of stock options they capped
off bonuses and things like that now
that may be fine for Eli Lilly but you
kind of wonder about what happens if a
lot of companies did that I mean it's
the incentives that he actually drives
the innovation that really motivates
people and I think taking these things
out is not necessarily a good result for
shareholders it may mitigate risk but it
may substantially reduce the returns for
companies as well
we employed a very rigorous and
methodical methodology and it took a
long time to do that I mean this book
was almost three years in the making and
with each feature in governance we went
through and collected all the literature
both from academics and professionals we
looked at the data that was available
and we looked through you know the
popular press to find examples of things
that companies are specifically doing in
these areas and we also added interviews
that we conducted with third-party
experts consultants lawyers and
practitioners including directors and
executives and we took all that
information and digested it together in
a way that we believe gives the most
comprehensive look at all areas of
governance
in the media
older discussions and things like that
there's I think there's lots of things
that are that are missing first off I
think people are trying to do the right
thing you know you want to highlight and
penalize people where they've had bad
governance and they're doing kind of bad
things so I think that that's a good
thing the issue is what mechanism do you
want to use to isolate the ones that are
the good ones for the bad ones
I think what's missing is everybody or
most people out there are really trying
to find here's a very very simple
yardstick for measuring corporate
governance do you have this many
directors of this type or you know do
you use the pay of this form things like
that but I think the problem is it's a
lot more complicated than that
there are certain differences in
organizations and people corporate
strategies and things like that that
that that basically make a simple
yardstick a place to start but not a
place they end up you have to think more
carefully about what are the choices and
it's not a one-size-fits-all set of
choices for evaluating corporate
governance
boards face lots of sensitive issues in
and the issues that are really sensitive
vary over time in the 1990s 2000 2000s
you know we had lots of auto failures
the board was very concerned about our
is the audit function appropriate do we
have sufficient internal controls the
Audit Committee of the board was under
tremendous scrutiny and now what you see
is that the Compensation Committee is
that is the committee and the decisions
that they're making are the ones that
are tremendous scrutiny is it CEO pay
too high or repaying the people the
right form and there's lots of people on
the outside both media but also proxy
advisory firms that are that are
weighing in on this and it's it actually
now is going to shareholder vote through
the so-called say-on-pay so I'd say
that's a tremendously sensitive issue
for the boards the other issues that are
that are sensitive our risk management
do we actually know what's going to
happen if we have a subside a hiccup in
the the inputs or the outputs of the
firm you know if you have an earthquake
in in Japan how how does it affect where
they're gonna be able to get our raw
material do we have plans in place and
things like that what what happens to us
if all the sudden interest rates go up
or we lose a major customer you know
what is our strategy capable of dealing
with that so lots of boards are trying
to deal with with risk management in one
key part of it that we've seen certainly
around around the country recently it's
a session planning do they actually have
somebody the complot that's going to
plug in do we know who that person is
how comfortable do we feel about that as
we replace management I think what's
going to happen going forward is I think
the next committee of the board is the
nominating Governance Committee this
tremendous scrutiny now about do we have
sufficient diversity on boards do we
have the right board members you know
the people that come up for evaluation
for new board memberships or actually
come up through the govern the
nominating Governance Committee so how
that committee operates so they're doing
the right thing are they picking the
right people those kind of things I
think are clear
on horizon
the book has lots of important takeaways
one of them is that I think you want to
be very cautious following blue-ribbon
panel recommendations or you know things
that you read in the press or whatever
presumed to be best practices and when
we look at these things in the book from
a research perspective if a lot of these
things just don't hold up some of them
are clearly fine but some of them some
of them not so I think the the book
really lays it out in a pretty neutral
way and gets in there and says what do
we actually know about things like
should the CEO and the chairman the
board be separated you know what do we
know about how Jesus structure pay and
things like that but I think that the
primary message of the book is you have
to think a little harder about
governance choices you just can't fall
all these these standard recommendations
yeah in terms of pressing development so
the thing we worry about is for lack of
a better term the federalization of
corporate governance we certainly have
seen sarbanes-oxley and go into place it
was directed mostly at the accounting
function and other other features of the
board
more recently the the dodd-frank bill
which is which has been passed at some
form all those being litigated really
opens up the board to to lots of
inquiries that are basically imposed on
them by the government so one of the
things is they're opening up proxy
access under the rubric of shareholder
democracy so if if you your shareholder
you ought to be able to vote you know in
America and and have some impact on
these things with regard to directors
that are elected and things like that
one of the proposals is if you've owned
three percent you or a group have
collectively owned three percent of the
company for three years you can nominate
25 percent of the board for election so
instead of having elections where
they're mostly uncontested accepting
proxy contests you have a situation here
where the outsiders can bring board
members to forward for potential
elections to the board now that's
something that's being imposed on the
companies that's not something they
would do necessarily as their free will
and you kind of wonder you know is that
a is that a good consequence or not
basically we've actually done a little
research around this we find that those
kind of proposals seem to be greeted
with big negative stock price responses
for companies that look like they're
gonna be subject to these to these
criteria so there's a case where you
know the government has in some sense
decided that's a good idea have kind of
passed this thing but it's like the
research results are suggesting maybe
it's not such a good idea so hopefully
you know the research like that will
inform regulators in the government you
know what might be a good thing to do
but I think right now in the
administration there's there's a lot of
interest in imposing govern
criteria on company that that really you
know could have been voluntarily adopted
and weren't and that you know the I
don't know the trillion-dollar question
is is that is that good or not is it
better to have regulation or is it
better to let the the market operate of
course that's the age-old question in
economics and I think here's a case
where I think we can't weigh in a little
bit on this and but I think the
federalization of corporate governance
is a is a big